in 10,5 prozent für die fdp bei der
europawahl nach dem jetzigen stand und
jörg nolte hat sich geäußert in berlin
gehören auch mal rein
wir wollen diese europäische union
endlich wieder in den dienst der bürger
stellen
wir wissen mit was sie uns beauftragt
haben dass rufe ich unseren wählern zu
wir nehmen diesen auftrag sehr ernst und
wir wissen dass wir sie nicht
enttäuschen dürfen wir werden alles
dafür tun dass wir in den nächsten fünf
jahren dort ein sehr gute arbeit
abliefern
ich glaube auch ich glaube auch das wird
jetzt leichter
also bis jetzt ja ich habe im wahlkampf
darüber geflachst york allein in brüssel
das endet jetzt mit dem heutigen tag und
ich bin sehr sehr froh
wir haben stattdessen jetzt eine
bärenstarke truppe bis jetzt von zehn
abgeordneten so sieht das aus ich glaube
aber diesen vorläufigen ergebnissen noch
nicht so recht weil ich weiß sie sind um
18 uhr noch hoch volatil
da kann auch eine ganze menge geschehen
warten wir ab wie der abend weiter läuft
ich bin zunächst über mal übrigens auch
sehr froh dass wir in bremen
offensichtlich drin sind wenn die erste
hochrechnung hier sieben prozent bringt
dann heißt das wir sind keinesfalls
rausgekegelt was ja viele sich gewünscht
haben
wir lassen uns aus den parlamenten nicht
mehr raus gegen die befreundet die
zeiten sind in deutschland vorbei das
war das erste statement von erneuten dem
fdp spitzenkandidaten für die europawahl
und auch bisher schon mitglied im
europäischen parlament und mein kollege
alexander keller hat vor wenigen
momenten mit ihm auch sprechen können
am heuten die prognosen sagen 10,5
prozent für das europäische parlament
sie sind der spitzenkandidat der partei
sie werden sicherlich mehr erhofft haben
sind sie jetzt auch besonders
verantwortlich für dieses ergebnis
also erstmal einmal 50 prozent zuwachs
gegenüber dem letzten gegenüber der
letzten wahl wenn sie
leute suchen die verantwortung
übernehmen könnten desaströses
wahlergebnis müssen sie bei cdu und spd
suchen
da werden sie fündig denn die sind
wirklich eingebrochen wir sind um 50
prozent gestiegen
aber sie haben sich auf sehr viel mehr
erhofft man erhofft sich immer mehr
ich glaube auch nicht dass das das ende
der fahnenstange ist sondern ich bin
ganz zuversichtlich dass wir danach
steigen mir erscheint das angesichts der
stimmung die ich erlebt habe in der
partei wie in der bevölkerung ganz
erstaunlich wenig also ich hatte
persönlich mit 12 13 schon gerechnet
wenn eine partei in ihrem wahlprogramm
fordert das parlament für dass sie
kandidiert letztendlich abzuschaffen war
das so eine gute idee aus einer sicht
der stimmenmaximierung vielleicht nicht
aber wir sind ehrlich und wir wollen den
bürgern reinen wein einschenken also zu
sagen wir haben das überhaupt nicht im
sinn wollen es versuchen es dann aber
doch zu machen wäre unredlich und man
muss manchmal auch unpopuläre
forderungen in den raum stellen wenn man
überzeugt ist dass es richtig ist
insofern ja ich meine schon dass wir
dass wir da den korrekten geraden weg
gegangen sind
mag sein dass uns das ein bisschen
zustimmung gekostet hat wie auch dass
wir den wechsel als ultima ratio ins
fenster gestellt haben da seien viele
dass die dexxit partei sind wir
überhaupt nicht aber das haben andere
für sich zu nutzen versuchen vielleicht
sind sie damit partiell durchgedrückt
wir müssen das noch analysieren schauen
wir mal in bremen gab es auch stimmen
gewinnen wir gegenüber den letzten 45
prozent zunahme an stimmen aber trotzdem
nur sieben prozent
wie würden sie das ergebnis in bremen
bremen ist nur ein sehr spezifischer
fall das wissen sie selbst bremen ist
ein 13 tief links geprägte stadt
ich glaube es gibt kein schwereres
spielfeld für für die afg als bremen
es kommt hinzu dass er in bremen
praktisch keinen wahlkampf machen
konnten also sie wissen um das attentat
auf frank marx netz sie werden davon
gehört haben dass ein spitzenkandidatin
der spitzenkandidat der auf dem im
januar ein attentat verübt wurde der
wurde er übel zugerichtet
ein anderes parteimitglieder 28 jährige
frauenschwarm ist so im bauch getreten
worden beim plakatieren dass sie das im
krankenhaus behandelt werden musste
veranstaltungsräume haben wir gar keine
gefunden ich konnte nicht zu einer
einzigen veranstaltung nach bremen
fahren weil die sagten wir haben einfach
keine räume niemand traut sie uns zu
vermieten die einschüchterungsversuche
der linksterroristen von der antifa sind
so manifest das traut sich keiner mehr
wähler dann auch einschüchtern lassen
nach dieser logik
vorsicht vor sich also sieben prozent
ist für bremer verhältnisse durchaus ein
respektables ergebnis
also nochmal die stadt ist wirklich
krass links geprägt und wenn wir da 7
prozent wir haben dann noch eine relativ
starken konkurrenten mit www 100 bürger
in wut dann ist das schon respektabel
wie ich meine
soweit jörg morgen im phoenix interview
danke dass ihr an enke